This is a plug.
And last year, research revealed that eight out of ten modern men...
...are not entirely sure how to wire it up.
And this is where man finds himself these days.
10,000 years in the making,...
...10,000 years of endeavor in science and the arts and the humanities...
...and within one generation,...
...he's been reduced to a feckless, bed-wetting, Parmesan-shaving imbecile...
...who revels in his own uselessness.
Something has to be done.
Welcome to Man Lab,...
...the grueling arena in which the terminal decline of man will be arrested and possibly even reversed.
In this humble industrial building, we will revive and relearn the skills that defined man.
And drag them, glittering, onto a broad, sunlit upland of being a proper chap.
Well, we'll be doing some woodwork, anyway and maybe a bit of plumbing.
Man Lab is the workshop where we kick-start the stalled evolution of the male species.
It's a bloke's base camp for an epic assault on the north face of Mount Ignorance.
A repository of ingenuity and invention...
...where man can emerge blinking yet triumphant,...
...armed with only a decent tool kit and a slim volume of English poetry.
Man Lab is a hallowed place where things get done properly.
And a chap can still enjoy a half-decent pint.
It's excellent.
In this series, we sweep away the confusion that has reigned since the coming of moisturizer and the male makeover...
...and guide us back onto the true path of enlightenment.